is
good morning
good morning
everyone canadians have worked hard to
overcome incredible challenges
the sacrifices and hardships of the
pandemic have been greater than we could
have imagined
thousands
lost a loved one
businesses struggled as we all stayed
home
moms dads and kids had to adapt to a new
reality while seniors suffered in
isolation
the federal government had the backs of
canadians and canadians
rose to the moment
with choosing compassion
hard work
and resilience
criminals
and it has shaken financial markets war
in ukraine is having a heavy impact on
global trade and the price of things we
all rely on
canada alongside our democratic partners
is helping ukraine defend itself against
authoritarianism
it's the right
and necessary thing to do
and canadians
are responding to these challenges with
the same resolve and resilience they've
demonstrated over the last two years
even in tough times
canadians are as determined as ever to
build a better future for themselves for
our children and grandchildren
and for the rest of the world
six months ago
canadians gave parliament
clear marching orders to deliver on this
better future
by investing in a strong and growing
middle class
more good well-paying jobs
economic growth and climate action
housing and child care affordability
better health care
and continued reconciliation with
indigenous peoples
the message from canadians was as clear
as the mandate they gave parliament
work together to put people and families
first
deliver results
and build a better future
this is what canadians expect
from their politicians
today i'm announcing that the liberal
party has reached an agreement with the
new democratic party to deliver results
for canadians
now
this supply and confidence agreement
starts today and will be in place until
the end of this parliament in 2025.
what this means is that during this
uncertain time
the government
can function with predictability and
stability
present and implement budgets
and get things done for canadians
i thought
long and hard about this it was not an
easy decision
with so much instability around us
canadians need stability
we're different political parties we
stand for different things
but where we have common goals
we cannot let our differences
stand in the way of delivering what
canadians deserve
that's why we're taking this step
both parties have identified key policy
areas
where we share similar objectives
and we've agreed to work together to put
the needs and interests of canadians
first
this agreement is not about compromising
the core beliefs of either of our
parties or denying the differences
between us
what it is about is making sure that
those differences
don't stand in the way of delivering for
canadians
we both believe
firmly
in parliament's role of keeping the
government accountable
this agreement maintains that critical
function we'll continue to engage in
healthy debate with each other and
disagree on things just like we'll also
continue working with other parties in
the house of commons to reach consensus
and make progress together
this is what working together
constructively
is all about
and we look forward to working with any
parliamentarian from any party who wants
to deliver
for the good of all canadians
is
and predictably in order to deliver the
goods
in questions
is
nobody benefits
when increasing polarization dysfunction
or obstruction dominate our parliament
when toxic
toxic partisanship prevents us from
agreeing on simple truths and facts
when parliament doesn't work properly
progress stalls on the important and
urgent issues canadians expect solutions
to
this agreement
is about focusing on what we agree on
instead of what we disagree on
on what unites us
instead of on what divides us
every piece of legislation will continue
to get the scrutiny it merits committees
will continue to do their essential work
and members of parliament will continue
representing their constituents and
holding the government to account
no priority
is
oh
we will make life more affordable
we know that rising housing costs are
putting real pressure on canadians so
we'll keep building affordable housing
we'll also crack down on unfair
practices and implement a home buyers
bill of rights
and will deliver changes that make
owning a home more accessible for middle
class families and first-time homebuyers
can count on us to continue delivering
the change they deserve
that's why we'll keep investing so that
ten dollar a day child care is a reality
for all families in canada because we
believe that every child should get the
best start in life and that every parent
especially every mom
should be able to afford to pursue the
career they want
like
foreign
canadian workers including ensuring
that 10 days of paid sick leave for all
federally regulated workers starts as
soon as possible this year
and continuing to support labor unions
we will keep moving forward on truth and
reconciliation with first nations inuit
and metis peoples
as part of this we'll make more
investments in indigenous housing this
year continue addressing violence
against indigenous women and girls and
be there to support the survivors of the
residential school system
we will deliver a fairer tax system for
the middle class by addressing the
profits made by financial institutions
during the pandemic and we will work
together to strengthen our democracy and
eliminate barriers to voting and
participation
all these are things that we had in our
platform all these are things that we
committed to canadians that we would
work hard on
and constructively on
and that's what this agreement is about
it's about fulfilling the clear mandate
canadians gave parliament
by improving the way we do politics so
we can act now to deliver good jobs
climate action more affordable housing
and child care a stronger middle class
and a better
more prosperous future for everyone
thank you
to
so we'll be starting with questions in
the room uh reporters here have agreed
to take to do one question each no
follow-ups because of the number of
people this morning we'll also be taking
questions on zoom raise your hand on
zoom please if you want to ask questions
good morning prime minister um the ndp
has not expressed support for increased
defense spending despite the evolving
situation in europe you are on route to
the nato summit today
does this mean that canada will not be
quickly seeking to increase our share of
defense spending to two percent of gdp
um other allies are increasing their
spending what's the plan disagreement is
about working together constructively in
the areas where there is agreement
and in the areas where there is not
agreement we will continue to do the
things that the liberal party
was elected to do and we'll look for
support from other parties as necessary
as we move forward in regards to the
situation in ukraine canada is pleased
to be increasing its contributions to
nato as a
enhanced forward presence and the
operation reassurance
we continue to stand with ukraine and i
give all the support we can we continue
to condemn
the
illegal and increasingly horrific
war by vladimir putin and i look forward
to engaging with our partners at nato
and in europe uh on
over the next couple of days
um
by the time this deal expires in 2025
you will have been in office for almost
10 years
are you committed to staying on and
running another election campaign in
that year or do you imagine a leadership
race within your party as i said a
number of times i'm planning on
continuing to serve canadians
through and beyond the next election
crystal the global
hi there prime minister thank you for
taking my question were there
discussions to make this a formal
coalition and give the ndp cabinet seats
and why didn't that happen
um after the last election
uh i made it very clear in my
response to canadians that i knew that
parliamentarians needed to work together
to deliver concretely for canadians and
that was the message we've heard from
canadians clearly over the past couple
of elections
and therefore
conversations began with the new
democrats on the areas in which we saw
an ability to work together
to be able to make parliament function
better to be able to continue to deliver
on ambitious initiatives
for canadians that in a time of
uncertainty canadians deserve
that was our focus every step of the way
we saw in the previous parliament what
happened
to even issues where there was consensus
in the house
that got dragged down that got slowed
down
and we weren't able to deliver as much
as we wanted to but as much as canadians
deserved
from a government that wants to be there
to have people's backs
so
what we're able to do with this one is
offer the stability that will allow
us to continue to work hard on fighting
climate change on building more housing
on delivering on the many things that
canadians expect from a strong
progressive government
and that's exactly what this is all
about
yeah robson good evening press
good morning the ndp's priorities for
many years have included pharmacare and
dental care are either of those things
something you had to promise them in
order to get this deal
we recognize that
moving forward on delivering for
canadians
we aligned on on the broad themes doing
more on healthcare doing more on the
environment doing more on housing
these are things that we got elected to
do more on
and finding areas of agreement where we
could move forward with the ndp we have
a number of liberals who for a long time
have been talking about the need to
continue moving forward on pharmacare
continuing uh to expand supports for
low-income canadians including with
dental care so these are things that fit
within our universe of priorities
but uh are easy uh to move forward on in
a constructive way that assures that on
a broad range of issues
parliament gets to focus on delivering
for canadians
parliament will be able to
be there
to continue to support canadians why
people while people work across party
lines in all parties
to make that a reality
well we can work with other parties
climate change reconciliation
these are all things
that are very hard
charles toronto star uh good morning sir
a lot of your comments seem to be
addressing concerns in your own party
and perhaps in your new dance partner's
party that everyone can still do their
job and do what they came to do here but
i i'm i'm confused as to what limits
this agreement and the support like what
defines confidence do you do you have a
definition of that is it only money
bills when it comes to defense spending
for example will the ndp's view of that
veto what you want to do in ukraine
i think it's important to say that it's
not just about
reassuring people that
the
[Music]
formulas of parliament will be respected
both of our parties understand deeply
how important it is for people to have
confidence
not just in government but in our
democratic systems
that we're in a time where we are seeing
around the world challenges to
democracies erosion of democracies
and that's where the role of
parliamentarians
to hold governments to account to ask
tough questions
to demand transparency and openness is
continues to be at the center
of our working relationship with the ndp
and with all other parties
we know that delivering for canadians
needs to at the same time reassure them
that democracy is strong and that
government is being held to account
and that's exactly what this agreement
is focused on saying there are broad
areas in which we agree we should be
able to work constructively together and
not have parliament be obstructive
so we can deliver for canadians
but at the same time
point out that democracies can be strong
not only when they're toxic
or
hyper partisan
but when they're also collaborative and
focused on delivering concretely for
canadians that's what this is about
well
um
is
yes
and quebecers
yes sir your own platform last fall
didn't include
pharmacare or dental care in any sort of
detailed way you're already projected to
run large deficits over the last over
the next couple of years how will this
fit into the government's financial
picture
we remain
committed as liberals
to both being there to have canadians
backs and
being there for fiscal responsibility
we demonstrated during this
pandemic that the best way to grow the
economy and get our jobs back and get
businesses roaring back was by making
historic investments to support
canadians
we know that support for canadians and
economic growth goes together that it
has to be done in a fiscally responsible
frame and that's absolutely what we will
always do
nothing in this agreement
prevents us from continuing to be
responsible stewards of the public purse
and delivering for canadians in a way
that creates growth and opportunity for
all into the coming years
and that's what we're going to stay
focused on
tom perry cbc hi prime minister i know
you say that canadians elected mps to
work together
and i know you said there's still going
to be debate uh and under this deal but
canadians gave you a minority
and you are in effect giving yourself a
majority so is this what canadians voted
for
um
the
conclusions drawn by
analysts by canadians by political
parties following the last election
is that
it's a minority government so parties
need to work together
that's what a minority government means
it means canadians in this difficult
time wanted elected the government with
an ambitious platform for canadians on
health care on housing on environment
on reconciliation
but
they gave a minority government
because they said
you need to work with other parties to
get this done
that's exactly what this agreement is
about
it's about saying in the areas where we
have alignment with the ndp
we're going to work together
constructively to deliver for canadians
in these times of challenge and
uncertainty
and in areas we don't agree with the ndp
we're going to need to continue to work
with other parties
on advancing the priorities of canadians
that's what this agreement
is and it is a responsible
answer to the uncertainty we're in to
the challenges facing democracies uh
with hyper partisanship and toxic
polarization of saying
let's actually make deliberate efforts
to work across party lines so we can get
the things done for canadians the
canadians voted for in that in the last
election in voting for a number of
different parties with similar
approaches
that's the focus we have this is about
demonstrating that even in times of
challenge and difficulty
governments can come together with
parties to get things done for canadians
good morning
other things which we have always done
[Music]
in this world of uncertainty
um
and predictability
the
focus that we have as a liberal party
has always been on
delivering on an ambitious platform
to have canadians back to grow the
economy to fight climate change to stay
fiscally responsible while creating
greater opportunities for all canadians
that doesn't change
when following the last election we saw
the level to which there was alignment
on many of those key themes with
the new democratic party
we started talking about ways we could
ensure that on the areas we agreed
parliament would function smoother and
we'd be able to deliver
more things for canadians at a time of
uncertainty
or canadians need their government to be
there for them
not
foundering in
partisanship and toxic divisions
so
this approach was always focused on you
know working together collaboratively
where we agree agreeing to disagree
where we don't
it was never about
um you know creating any greater formal
agreements or power sharing it was
always about saying look there's things
we agree on let's work constructively
together on that to deliver for
canadians
and that's exactly what we're announcing
today
thank you very much good day
thank you very much everyone